GAVIN: (In progress)-in service to his country,
both as part of Namibia's struggle for independence
and one of the most prominent and thoughtful
thinkers about what prosperity would look
like for an independent Namibia.
And so I want to welcome him here to the Council,
to welcome him back to New York.
And the president knows this city very, very
well, having studied at Fordham as an undergraduate,
I believe received your master's degree in
international relations from The New School
and spent several years with the United Nations
at the Secretariat as well.
So he knows us well and is fresh and rested
and hopefully invigorated by our beautiful
spring weather.
And with that, I turn it over to you, Mr.
President.
GEINGOB: Thank you very much.
I recognize old friends like Maurice Tempelsman.
Yes, we were friends for a long time and I
still see him being active.
There is Kramer (sp) also, I see, and old,
old friends, you know, many of them.
So thank you very much.
It's a great honor to be here to again exchange
views with friends and also people who advise
governments in policy matters and so on.
As you know, Namibia is a young democracy
still, but indeed a true democracy in the
true sense of the word.
Our governance architecture is in place.
We have regular free and fair elections.
Our macroeconomic architecture is also good.
Our banking system is working.
We get good ratings from rating agencies,
several B-positive but now a little bit of
some problems maybe.
But I just want to jump to social architecture,
where we have problems because we have a good
constitution, good policies, but people now
want to benefit from those good policies.
They would like to eat.
They would like to have accommodation-decent,
at least, accommodation, not luxury but at
least people want to live in something that
is livable.
And then also the thing of peace.
Democracy is good.
It's a better system because even if you are
quarreling-I keep on saying you don't have
to go to war when we are in a democratic dispensation.
So I tell people, yes, make noise, complain.
The moment you keep quiet I will know there's
something wrong.
And that I learned from your country when
I was student during the tough days of black
power struggle.
There was war here.
One professor at Lincoln said, people, 30
years ago were the black people better off
or worse off?
Then we said, so what?
Then he says, they were worse off but they
were so quiet; why we're not angry that time?
Then we couldn't answer that.
He said, you know-do you know, people, when
people have hope and they see a light at the
end of a tunnel, they make noise.
So they are hopeful.
So I always use that example in my country
that people are now so angry.
They want things done.
Sometimes I say, is it because I'm now the
president or what is it?
But then I think it's because they are hopeful.
So I tell them, the moment you keep quiet
I'll be worried, so demand, demand.
So we go by legacy.
We have legacy of founding president, who
was a freedom fighter who led us in the struggle
and took us back; reconciled people who were
warring, white, black, different tribes divided
by bantustans, put them together, and had
a peaceful transition, building on his legacies.
And then we got another president whom we
call stabilizer, a cool cat, very calm.
And then they say, now the person who comes
must be active and he must bring about prosperity.
That's a most difficult task.
And how do I do that?
I took all of last year with my team to kind
of have a rallying point.
How do I wait?
People 26, 25 years, some are losing hope,
so to energize them again so come up with
slogans like: building the Namibian house
where we're going to all live together peacefully
using bricks, our different tribes and races.
It was beautifully painted, you know, and
presented and it's now the talk, Namibian
house.
And I said, no one must feel left out from
that house-one Namibia.
So those things have reignited.
Now implementation.
So we came up with a plan that is called Harambee
Prosperity Plan.
Some say, why "harambee"?
That's a Swahili word.
Why not our own language worked?
We said, yes, we have so many languages.
If I were to choose my language you would
have said, oh, we are left out.
So I took a neutral language, Swahili language,
African-but African too, so therefore Harambee,
meaning pulling to get in the same direction.
So that's what we are now implementing.
I have my experts here.
My economic adviser was present.
I have also a group who will participate.
I don't talk alone.
We live in teamwork and that is the way we
do it.
Everywhere I go I let them talk.
After all, people paid for them to be here,
so they must also work so that I can say they
are also delivering.
So I have the-my wife, she's also active,
a business lady.
Then I have the deputy prime minister, who
is our foreign relations and cooperation person.
Then I have the economic-minister of economic
affairs and planning.
Then I have the minister of environment because
we are going to sign tomorrow the agreement,
so he is here for that.
But Namibia is a country where we have good
conservation policies so he can also pitch
in.
Our two ambassadors, and Dr. Steytler, my
economic adviser, the wife of our ambassador.
He used to be on my staff.
I sent him here to Washington when I was the
minister of trade-a trade representative.
So I have that big team, and it will be good
that we can do that.
Thank you very much.
GAVIN: Absolutely.
Well, thank you, Mr. President.
I think we already get a flavor of the energy
that you're bringing to the project.
And you have made poverty alleviation, poverty
elimination a huge priority for Namibia going
forward, but I want to draw you out on something
you and I had a chance to talk a little bit
about before we joined everyone.
You're building the Namibian house collectively
with your countrymen and women, and trying
to build this prosperous future.
And this is-you have tremendous human resources
in your country, clearly.
You have natural resources, but help in a
building project is always a good thing, be
it in the form of assistance or trade and
investment.
And can you talk to us a little bit about
how sometimes Namibia's success and Namibia's
status as upper-middle-income country can
make it challenging to access some of the
assistance that might make the road a bit
smoother or the journey a bit faster?
GEINGOB: Yes.
I used to argue with my colleague here when
he was a banker, when he was a governor of
the Bank, when I was raising that issue of
the higher-middle-income countries' status:
Why are you against being a rich country?
Just make it work.
Yes, it's true.
And before I say that, let me express my thanks
to President Bush administration.
During the time that Millennium Challenge
Account was being conceived we were left out,
Botswana and Namibia, because we are rich,
but they made an exception to include us.
And I must tell you, that's one project that
has made a mark in development in Namibia
when it comes to schooling, when it comes
to actually helping the conservation-excellent.
Libraries built-you know, big libraries that
you can-people-children go and study there.
You can see there is something that has been
left.
And we were one of the countries which implemented
it about 95 percent or so, and if not more.
So we are pleased for that, but unfortunately
it stopped.
So that status makes it that-because of success,
it makes it that we don't get any grants or
soft loans and so on.
And we came from a very bad situation-apartheid
colony where blacks were completely left out
educationally, politically, and otherwise.
And when we come from that background we are
told, since you are rich you can't get any
help.
That is not fair.
And if countries-I don't want to say it to
expose them, but we are making a joke out
of frustration: If you mismanage you are rewarded.
If you have piled up debts, the debts are
written off, you get loans-soft loans, grants.
But if you are successful trying to manage
your own affairs properly, they say you are
rich.
Some members are closing down and say, we're
going to poorer countries.
We say, wait.
And I had to take one of them and say, are
you going to close your embassy in America-(chuckles)-because
they were trying to give (my chief ?) an excuse
to say, since you are rich we are going to
a poorer country we can help.
So that is not fair, really.
But it also made us maybe to be independent,
maybe to rely on our own resources, to maybe
manage them properly and therefore to be transparent,
accountable, and depend on our own resources
and manage them properly, both human and material
resources.
So it's true.
It's not fair.
I think for a country which came from apartheid,
white-black situation where white people are,
because of history, rich and blacks are poor
and left out.
Now, I was at the World Bank for some short
time.
They told me, yes, your country is rich.
Your problem is that of redistribution of
that wealth.
And I said, are you saying I must go and grab
it from the whites and give it to the blacks?
Are you going to be happy with that because
you know there is this inequality?
Ah, yes, maybe we are but a few countries
who have highest coefficiency-Gini coefficiency.
And we have brought it down.
We are working with that, but it's still-and
you see all these countries where you have
this black-white situation, even the United
States.
For an advanced country it's still high, 4-about
4, you see?
And we are 5 now, 5-something, but we were
6-no, we were 7.
We brought it down.
So that is what you have inherited.
So although materially the country is rich
resource-wise, but when you look at people,
blacks-white, blacks in African countries:
poor.
And therefore, those who are poor have help
from other countries, but we are told we are
rich.
And that is very serious.
If we didn't manage Namibian reconciliation-being
a small country, we're not talk about.
We came before President Mandela.
South Africa whites were coming to my office
to talk to me: How did you manage it that
black and whites-and ours was a worse situation
because of lack of education.
Separation was complete, so to say.
South Africa, they were still mingling at
Cape Town University and so on at academic
level and so on, but ours was a complete separation.
But we took those people-and not only white-black.
There's also division among our own tribes.
The bantustans, you are this tribe, you go
there.
And we took those people, put them together,
have reconciliation, and manage everything
properly.
And South Africa was helped by that, that
former terrorists can be trusted.
They can create a very democratic situation
where all Namibians, all people are respected,
are welcome.
That's what we are talking about.
We are building a Namibian house.
We have different ethnic groups, races.
The bricks that we are using are our races
and colors, and laws we are passing in parliament
are that glue that is putting us together.
When you finish or you plaster it, you paint,
you no longer can identify individual tribes
or race.
That's a Namibian house I'm talking about.
That's what we are building and I think we
are making progress.
GAVIN: That's fascinating-especially considering
how much attention there is in this political
cycle here in the United States to income
inequality-to think about the experience in
Namibia.
Now, I want to follow up on what you were
talking about in terms of the example that
Namibia set for South Africa, and really a
broader question about how does a country
like Namibia-quite young; really by most metrics
extraordinarily successful-how does a country
like Namibia, though, that is small in population,
be influential regionally and globally?
Is it enough to lead by example?
I note, and I'm sure many others in the room
have noted, your own example.
You and the first lady have publicly disclosed
your assets.
You've insisted on your minister doing the
same.
Your predecessor was noted for emphasis on
accountably and good governance as well, won
the Ibrahim Prize.
Is it enough to lead by example?
Or does a voice like Namibia's need to be
heard more in regional and global fora to
tackle some of these other problems and to
present an alternative to the vision of some
countries on the continent where you do have
leaders who've been in place for decades?
GEINGOB: Yes, when you're a small country
it's difficult, even if you have good ideas.
I make a joke-I made a joke once when we are
looking for a Security Council seat.
I like to make jokes sometimes.
Then we think we must get two big countries.
Nigeria and South Africa are possible candidates.
So I say when we are talking, I say, you must
also be careful; we should also think of neutral
smaller country because wisdom is not only
confined to big powers.
We may be small but we went to the same schools,
so we may be the ones who can contribute more
by being neutral, knowing we are weak and
even less interested.
But that is a joke.
It's just how it works.
It will go to bigger countries.
Yes, Namibia is respected in Africa, maybe
because we have been in exile for too long,
working with people they know already, U.N.
Some would say we-Kramer (sp) will know that
we-(inaudible)-the United Nations.
We were having a council for Namibia, working
with others.
We are definitely respected, and we are also
resourced.
Investors don't come these days because of
good governance per se; they also come for
resources.
So if you have resources like uranium, the
things that people are looking for-right now
I will tell you, after my inauguration the
invitation list to me is unique that I'm invited
to pay a state visit will start from China,
Russia, France.
Those are all uranium-connected countries.
So these days everybody pays attention to
us because of resources we have.
And also in AU we have standing.
Our president-(inaudible)-in formation of
OAU.
So we are actually known in Africa.
We know African leaders.
And I was asked, again first, to go to Brazzaville
for inauguration of President Nguesso, and
you could see that I was the only English-speaking
person.
But that opportunity is there and people are
asking to consult.
So we are-we are recognized.
But how do we do that?
Example of good governance.
Good governance-effective governance, I call
it-and service delivery, first leading by
example, a (declaration ?) was done with PriceWaterhouse.
Some people came from here and they prepared
a paper for me that I could release: Namibia
must be a center for ethics, and you must
now invite the leaders from Africa to have-(inaudible).
"Hey, don't go there."
Africa, there is respect for elders and so
on.
How do I-first, I am so new as a president.
And many people think I've very young, but
I'm older than many of them, by the way, some
of the presidents, but they all think that
I'm younger than them, and I take it that
way.
And how do I invite, as a young person, older
people to come and lecture them?
That's not how we do it.
But if you live by example, example is like
keeping time.
Small things.
When I was appointed to the Cabinet I had
to ask CVs from ministers.
They first thought I was trying to interfere
in their business.
There are resistance.
The CVs, then trying to match the skills with
the position they're going to hold.
Then, after that, appointed them contract,
management-I mean, the performance contracts.
Again, these are new things, then to say why
is this man trying to dictate to us, and so
on?
And then I go in and I'm telling them it's
for I have to deliver now.
Our task is to deliver.
Others were setting up the stage, the foundation
for peace, unity, democracy.
But democracy, now, people don't eat democracy.
They want food, shelter, so therefore you
must to enhance all of us so that can work
in deliverance.
Time-keeping.
If my Cabinet meeting is to start 9:00, it
must start 9:00.
The first time ministers will come in maybe
late, they saw me and the second time they
are there 9:00 sharp.
The meeting starts; 1:00 we go out, and then
to go and work.
And then involving the people.
Town hall meetings concept I copied from you
people.
And I went to all 14 regions.
Many have ordinary people sitting there for
four or five hours, people talking, talking,
and then also other business people.
And so I engaged them-engaged people.
But I'm not alone-(inaudible)-them.
They all talk, because if I fail to explain
(the cold economics to them ?), and then come
up with the plan that we are calling Harambee
plan.
Now, that, it went through.
Africa-first Kenyans liked it because we are
using their Swahili word.
East Africans say, oh, that's very good.
And then that then is now going around.
So that kind of things are small things, but
you recognize-and you must be humble also.
We are very respectful to elders, to senior
people.
As I said, African leaders, I behave like
I am the youngest.
But almost, except for a few, most of them
I'm older than them.
But they were longer in their office; therefore
they are senior to me.
So, yes, Namibia will still make headway.
We are just starting.
GAVIN: Indeed.
It's easy to forget how young the country
is.
And it's also young demographically, like
so much of Africa.
Over half the population I think, of Namibia,
is under the age of 25.
And so then most Namibians were born after
independence.
And as you say, what they want is-
GEINGOB: We call them "born-frees."
(Laughter.)
GAVIN: Indeed, the born-frees-just as in South
Africa, the born-frees.
And the challenge of meeting the demands of
the born-frees, right, who are exposed to
the same images of wealth and prosperity on
social media that any young person here is,
have the same aspirations for their future,
brings me back to this question about poverty
alleviation and creating new economic opportunity.
And I guess a couple parts to my question.
First, do those young people-do they participate
in these town halls?
Is that how you hear from them?
Is that the mechanism?
Or are they finding new means of political
expression?
And then, you know, when you're looking to
solve the big problem-the job creation imperative,
the economic future of the country, given
that foreign assistance is largely not available
because of Namibia's status, trade and investment-the
theory of the case, right, is that the private
sector should fill that gap; trade and investment
should fill that gap.
Where is that happening and where is it not?
I know there's significant Chinese investment,
certainly in Namibia-I believe more than 40
Chinese firms operating, bringing in-according
to an article I recently read-some 4.6 billion
U.S. dollars in revenue annually.
Are you seeing the same kind of aggressive
investment strategy from other economic powers?
GEINGOB: Yes, they should.
We have a slogan that I coined: Namibia is
a child of international solidarity, midwifed
by United Nations, so friend to all, enemy
to none.
That's the cornerstone of our foreign policy.
And therefore, when we are saying, now, government
must look towards those who are needy and
provide conducive environment for those who
are able to be on their own, using the conducive
investment climate we are providing, an invitation
is open to everybody.
Canadians are also there in a big way with
that kind of-mention the Chinese with the
mining sector, uranium, and also copper.
I just launched the smelter acid plant in
Tsumeb two weeks ago.
The Canadians are there.
I had a very good, successful visit by congressional
delegation led by Senator Flake.
We are going to receive a business delegation
in May, Ambassador-in May, yeah.
And it's open to everybody.
Chinese factor is a factor-reality in the
world.
You know, I'm a Waldorf Astoria person.
I was put there the first time by Tempelsman
and them, and I said, why are they putting
me in that place?
I discovered it is a cheaper one compared
to where I was staying, in the Continental
Hotel-far, far cheaper.
So we are scared of Waldorf.
So can you imagine a landmark like Waldorf
Astoria to have been bought by Chinese?
Here in New York City.
They are everywhere, the Chinese.
It's a big population.
And Namibia of course has to be careful, because
I was in Lusaka when the TAZARA road was being
built.
We never saw Chinese socializing.
But of course we have to also give credit
that the Chinese have opened up even China.
But in Namibia we are already seeing-what
do you call them-(inaudible)?
You see the children coming.
That's very serious, because if you have a
child, you can bring the family to see the
children.
It's family.
So, being a small population, you have to
be careful.
One day you will wake up only 1 million, 2
million.
(Chuckles.)
So it's a-it's a reality, but they are saying
they have opened up to the world.
They are in America.
They are everywhere.
But we always say we had a very difficult
struggle to free ourselves.
Not supported some of the American government,
as I said the other day, supported by those
former communist countries.
We fought to free our country, and I don't
think any of them are going to take over,
will exchange that freedom to be recognized
by any other person.
We tell Chinese that.
And I copy that statement that I got from
them when I went to China as a minister of
trade, because there was nearly a fistfight
in Namibia because they were bringing ordinary
workers.
The unemployment is so high.
They were not obeying our laws, the labor
laws.
So I said, before you are going to fight,
let me go and tell them what is happening
and what could happen very soon.
So I went there and then they told me-you
know, and I saw sort of Americans there and
I said, oh, comrades, what's happening?
Americans are taking over here.
They said they have opened up 30 years ago.
They are privatizing and they are open.
But-that "but" is very important-whoever is
here comes on our own terms.
So I keep on telling them, don't forget what
you are telling us.
When you come to Namibia you must also come
on our own terms, and great win-win situation.
And I will not deny that we are happy with
some of the investments.
First, we don't eat uranium.
We don't even know-Namibians don't know what
is uranium.
Diamonds, some ladies are now wearing it but
it's not something we eat.
But somebody must need it who add economic
value to it.
And China wants to get uranium for whatever
reason.
I think that I don't even know-Namibians want
to eat.
And they come and build a company, a mine
in a desert, build a highway there; 2,000
people who were in the streets are housed,
with running water and lights.
I said, that's good.
That's investment.
However-however, how do we benefit from that
to a great win-win situation-always quoting
them.
So firstly we agreed your laws must apply,
because I told them, if you don't obey our
laws, our labor laws-overtime must be paid.
You cannot bring wheelbarrow pushers because
of already high unemployment.
Therefore, bring only experts, but not to
bring who do the ordinary work, and not to
compete with retail business, with Namibians
that are involved-small people.
So we did all those things.
So there is no way we, as a land of the brave-we
are not just called "land of the brave" for
a joke.
We fought South Africa, you know?
Even if you compare us with ANC and so forth,
we are fighting South African army.
So we don't believe-and are a very proud people.
We are saying "the land of the brave" very
proud and very maybe (it's base pride ?). But
we are not going to exchange our freedom with
anybody else coming to take it.
We are very strict and we are-we respect them,
they respect us, to tell the truth.
I met the president of China already two times.
So respect is there, but we've put our case,
where we stand.
I want to cooperate.
And we see there is respect.
There is serious respect.
And we Africans now believe in that too, not
actually we're taken as small boys who don't
know anything, and so on.
I think we want to matter-as we are saying
on Namibia's role, we want to matter in world
affairs.
And if Chinese can build us up, if the Russians
are now coming back to compete with you and
they respect me, if President Obama respects
that, why not?
We're are actors in this world, small or not.
GAVIN: Clearly, clearly.
And the climate change element of your agenda
here alone sort of is symbolic of that, right?
You're here, and you're here in person to
underscore the importance of this not just
for Namibia but for the world.
Well, at this point I'd like to invite members
to join the conversation.
Please remember that this meeting is on the
record.
And if you'd like to ask a question just go
ahead and turn your name card to vertical
and I'll do my best.
I might not be able to see your name because
of the angles, but we'll soldier on.
And when you're selected, please do speak
into a microphone.
State your name and affiliation.
And if I could please just ask everyone to
keep their question concise.
Even at the Council it's rare to get such
a treat to have an opportunity to chat with
a head of state, and so we don't want to lose
time delivering a lot of our own remarks.
So with that, why don't we start with Maurice
Tempelsman?
Q: Thank you, Michelle.
Coming back to the Harambee plan, which is
a very well-thought-through and comprehensive
roadmap, and then moving to what you indicated
as being a new president but you bring to
this position a rare and unusual combination
of qualities, the first one obviously a political
knowledge and sensitivity but you're also
blessed with the capacity or reputation of
being a terrific administrator.
And that brings to mind a question or point,
lens through which a former president of a
neighboring country-where Ambassador Gavin
used to stay-Festus Mogae, and he was fond
of saying: If everything is a priority, then
nothing is a priority.
Looking at it through that lens, what are
your priorities in terms of execution of your
Harambee plan?
GEINGOB: Well, as I said-thank you, Maurice.
We've come a long way.
Yes, I sort of learned through that long experience
to be a team player.
That's a strong-you know, so I have team.
John, can you-or first I've decided on Minister
Tom Alweendo.
I have the deputy prime minister.
So they all must play a role.
But let's start, since you are our planning
minister and economic minister.
ALWEENDO: Thank you, Comrade President.
Thank you, Comrade President.
Maybe to just start off with what we have-start
off by saying, you know, the time has come
for, I think, Namibia to do some extraordinary
things.
Twenty-six years, people are now demanding
different things, not more like-you know,
yes, we have the peace but now we need to
develop prosperity.
But that can only happen if we are going to
do certain things, and hence the Harambee
plan, which has got, you know, pillars, those
seven pillars which we realize that we need
to do.
You know, we talk about economic transformation.
We talk about governance and deliveries.
We talk about infrastructure development.
Those are all important pillars which we need
to embrace, invest in, for us to be able then
to develop the prosperity which we need.
But that can also only happen with the assistance
of our partners.
I mean, earlier on we were talking about,
you know, us being an upper-middle-income
country and therefore not getting the assistance
we-other people are getting.
But there is also something I think we can
still get from our partners.
We talk about, for example, in the Harambee,
the economic transformation.
That transformation of the economic can take
place only if we industrialize.
And we have agreed that we need to industrialize.
And Namibia-and not only Namibia, also the
whole continent, that transformation through
industrialization can only also happen if
we start by adding value to the commodities
which you all export from the continent.
There we can get some assistance from our
partners, and that assistance in terms of
how we trade-how we've been trading all this
time.
The value addition we are talking about on
the commodities which we export in raw forms,
we need to engage the private sector because
it's the private sector naturally that has
been the exporters of those raw materials.
And by and large, those private sectors are
not always African private sectors.
It's private sectors usually from developed
nations.
And therefore, we would like to have our partners
from those countries to agree with us, to
say their multinational companies need to
agree to add values to our raw materials.
And that's, I think, where I think we can
really get that partnership, that support
from the likes of you to encourage those multinationals
to play the same role which we want to play
by creating prosperity through industrializations
and through beneficiation of our commodities.
That is, I think, what I can say about the
Harambee.
But as I say, there are not only the transformation
but there are other pillars like, you know,
as I say, deliveries, governance, because
without governance-like we talked about earlier
on, people do start believing that, yes, these
are all possible things we can all do.
That is very, very important to have that
mindset that says, yes, we can achieve all
these big things which we have put ourselves
to deliver.
GEINGOB: And-(inaudible)-please, sir.
STEYTLER: Thank you, Comrade President.
Just to the question of Mr. Tempelsman, in
terms of priorities the plan is built around
four pillars.
But if I can single out two priorities that
His Excellency has singled out, number one
would be to fight corruption.
We have declared full-out war on corruption.
And therefore, in terms of the first pillar,
Maurice, we are targeting to become the most
accountable country on the African continent,
as measured by the Mo Ibrahim Index.
We are also planning to retain our space as
the country that's rated as the freest in
terms of price freedom, as measured by Reporters
Without Borders.
We also want to improve service delivery.
And one priority for us is also to become
the most competitive economy in Africa, not
just in SADC.
We are currently number five but we want to,
within a period of four years, say that we
are most competitive.
And for us to do that we are looking really
at a business environment.
We would like to streamline business processes,
making it easier for a business-the private
sector to operate, because the private sector
is the ultimate creators of wealth.
Then another key, key priority for the government
will be the declaration on poverty, the war
on poverty.
Now, this is a war that will have to be won
over many years, but under the Harambee period
we start with hunger poverty and we say that
no Namibians should die because of hunger.
Then there are also a key priority on vocational,
technical education, and also some priorities
in the area of infrastructure development.
So these are some of the priorities, Maurice,
that I can highlight from the plan.
Thank you.
GAVIN: Thank you all so much.
Gail Gerhart?
Q: Is this on?
GAVIN: The red light should come on.
There we are.
Oh, sorry.
Q: Could you explain to us the current relationship
of Namibia with the government of North Korea?
This has been publicized in the press now
and again, and it's been pointed out that
Namibia's in violation of the U.N. agreements
about cooperation with North Korea.
Can you give us an explanation of your current
position on that?
GEINGOB: Yes, thank you.
As I said, we used to fight apartheid regime
after we exhausted all peaceful means.
I came here as a young boy in '64.
And then I was made a petitioner at the U.N.,
begging everybody to help us, to free us peacefully.
The United States has relations with South
Africa, Israel, Portugal, those who were oppressing
our people at that time-bad regimes to me.
But because of national interest, you had
relations.
We're doing resolutions calling for us to
get our independence and human rights.
That's a national interest serving American
interests.
So after independence these countries continued
to have relations with us.
They helped us during the struggle, and therefore
we invite them to come and also join us as
we are doing even today, to be involved with
us to develop the country like any other business
asset.
Koreans came a long time ago to build the
statehouse that we are living in before the
sanctions, and that relationship was there.
And then we also had to build some structures
like the Heroes' Acre we call it, where people-like
you have a-what do you say, a grave you have
in Washington-Arlington.
GAVIN: Arlington National Cemetery.
GEINGOB: Arlington, yes.
So you have people who have sacrificed their
lives during the war and they must be buried
properly, or recognized.
We have that.
We have-(inaudible).
They built that.
So Koreans were there at that time, before
sanctions came.
Plus also some monuments.
If you go to Namibia, you will only see any
structure standing there is German structure,
nothing African.
But, remember, we had mud huts, so therefore
they cannot stand as structures.
So you only have these German structure.
We're bringing our own legacy also as people.
And don't say it's Chinese or Korean buildings.
It is our-we are the ones who, as I say, build
this and this.
Like, you got your famous Statue of Liberty;
it's a gift from France.
It's not you, but it's France.
So it's yours, so that's how we have those
structures, since it's been built by Koreans.
When the sanctions came in, we had to sit
down and see, where are we in conflict.
Nothing is retroactive, the way I was trained
by your universities that were mentioned.
The law that was not there when crime was
committed is not applicable to that situation.
So some of the things that build in our statehouse
was done before the sanctions came in.
Only sanctions now comprehensive was a recent
one of about-is 2006?
What is it?
MR./MS.
: (Off mic.)
GEINGOB: Yeah.
That is the only sanctions that we may be
in violation of.
We talk to the American ambassador, explain
to him, even before I came.
We made appointment with the chairman of the-of
the Sanctions Committee.
By the way, we should also be careful: Is
it the American sanctions or United Nations
sanctions?
Whose sanction is it?
Q: The United Nations sanctions.
GEINGOB: Oh, United Nations sanction.
So we are accountable to the United Nations,
not to Americans, OK?
(Laughs.)
So we are going to see that committee to explain
to them.
We are just going to report.
And it's not a question that we are committing
a crime.
These things are new, whereby they are testing
their nuclear weapons.
Even Chinese have complained.
So, now, that's a new development.
But what they were doing there was not illegal
or violating any sanctions.
But comprehensive sanctions, it's just about
two months out.
And that's what we are going to discuss with
them, how-in fact, we already comply when
the one company was listed, or two people
who are listed as maybe cover-undercover agents
for the regime, we sent them away.
So we complied with the sanctions.
But the one which is now comprehensive is
raising things like the defense headquarters,
which was-it started long time ago.
So we are going to discuss that with United
Nations.
But I'm glad to inform Americans that's what
we are doing.
GAVIN: Well, thank you very much, Mr. President.
And so, just to clarify, what I understand
you to be saying is that it is your position
that Namibia is accountable for adhering to
United-U.N. agreed-upon sanctions, and this
is-this is what the discussion is about.
GEINGOB: Yeah, I told the American ambassador
we are a United Nations creation.
There is no (way we consent in a way ?) of
violating United Nations resolution.
GAVIN: Thank you.
Thank you.
I'm sorry, it's a-it's my age, and I cannot
make-but the woman right in front of me, yes.
Thank you so very much.
I apologize for that.
Q: (Off mic.)
Oh.
(Comes on mic.)
Mojibau Aldoulou (ph) from Keokome (ph).
My question is about the born-free generation,
their aspirations, because how similar and
how different are those aspirations from that
of the older generation?
And especially in terms of education, from
what I gather, you know, there is a lot of
interest on the part of the government to
focus on vocational and technical education.
How does this jell with what the youth want
and their aspirations?
GEINGOB: Very good question.
Firstly, there is generational gap, I think.
We are, who are old-timers, when I'm campaigning,
I can go and tell the old people we fought
for freedom, you know how bad-how bad it was,
and they get-they connect.
Youth-my daughter, my kids-don't know; so
what, they may say: I'm unemployed, I want
education.
The information age people, they are on these
things.
They don't care about-we were talking about
how bad-how bad it was.
That's not their concern.
They are unemployed, they want education,
they want high-tech.
That's their concern.
So you will be wasting your time if you go
and talk to them about how we struggled against
South Africa.
You lose them.
So even vocational education, which looks
like you are taking them back to work with
hands, you have to be careful about that.
You have to actually talk to them, as I did
when I was director of U.N. Institute for
Namibia in Lusaka.
We had in our organization training-agriculture,
management-and we allowed them to register,
and there was zero interest in agriculture
because they thought agriculture was for blacks
who are oppressed, dirty your hands, and so
on.
So they didn't register voluntarily.
So I had to have talks with them to say, comrades,
you see, we're going to serve the masses.
Yes, yes, yes.
What's the population of Windhoek and other
towns I mentioned?
It came to about half a million, and Namibia
is about one-point-something million.
Now, where are the masses?
Oh, they're in the-in the rural areas.
Oh, comrades, therefore, agriculture is where
they are.
That's how you talk to them.
And that thing became oversubscribed, even
women.
So vocational training is their thing.
I make a joke when I'm talking: Ph.D.s do
not run the countries.
When we are sitting like this-concrete example:
if that air conditioner is out, with my Ph.D.,
I cannot fix it.
So it's people-and Germany was built by artisans.
We have German-we have a lot of Germans out
there, so I have to link to that.
Germans use their hands, and look at where
Germany is.
That's a talk you must give them.
Otherwise, you lose them.
And they are also getting their social-status
degrees; they cannot get jobs.
So they are educated, but on the street.
And that's what I was told about Boko Haram,
huh, that President Obama or someone was telling
me that-how it started.
The guy who was leader was having education,
Western education, degree, but he was unemployed.
So he says-other guys came and said, you are
educated in the Western world, you have education,
why are you unemployed?
That's how they say destroy Western education.
So same may be true of our young people: they
have degrees, but they are unemployed.
So it's a delicate thing.
They are a majority of voters, too, now, very
soon.
And they are demanding.
They are also acting in Namibia, deliberately
trying to-what do you call their muscles,
to show that they have power.
They just went and grabbed the land while
I was still campaigning-organized and grabbed
the land, and set a deadline of 31st of July
the economy was going to go up in flames.
And the party was divided.
I just became the leader of the party.
And people said, don't talk to them.
And first meeting of the-(inaudible)-I had
to expel them from the party, but as a president
I must talk to them.
So I held a meeting with them on the 24th
of July last year, six hours talks, allowing
them to make their case and sitting with them
for six hours.
That's how we preserved.
Maybe there could have been a-you could have
read in the papers Namibia is up in flames.
Small things happen like that, and therefore
talk, engage the people.
I told them, look, in democracy, you don't
have to go to war.
Bring up things here; we can talk.
So the good thing about democracy is a dialogue.
Diplomats are telling us, can't just go to
war when diplomacy fails.
So therefore, if you don't talk to young people,
and let them win also.
After we had educated them, they had a deadline
of 31st of July.
So I said, we are going to service the land.
After we talked, I said there should be no
loser.
So let's say we're going to service the land
from 27th of July up to 5th of August, so
you don't lose.
Because if we don't do it on your date, I
won.
So let's say that I just arrange, therefore
you also won-your day is included.
Great, a winning situation.
But listen to them.
They are very nasty.
I am also on the Facebook and social media.
I just engage them.
That's their dialogue, doing things.
And they appreciate, because you are encountering
them there, answering things, explaining.
And many of them, I may get five nasty tweets,
but about 95 percent will support me because
I explain the situation.
Engage them.
Engage them at their level.
That's the social media.
GAVIN: That's a little free political advice
for all of us.
Mr. Nakayama, yes.
Q: President, my is Nakayama, Citigroup.
I have a question about wisdom two countries
can share, U.S. and Namibia.
Two countries have a challenge.
Your country is very heterogeneous, like United
States.
Under your strong leadership, the country
has united.
What United States can learn from you or your
country about wisdom?
And, second, what United States should do
to create long-term, strong, sustainable relationship
with Namibia to become most important partner
to your country?
GEINGOB: Firstly, I must tell you-(laughs)-United
States taught me to how to put different people
together.
As I said, at the time of '60s, that's the
time of black power.
That's the time of burn, baby, burn.
And I also learn in this country that being-having
an open society, and during the Vietnam War
I used to see professors from Ivy League schools-Princeton-Richard
Falk was from Princeton, and I am from Columbia-debating.
Coming from South Africa-I mean, Namibia,
which isn't allowing those things, I said,
hey, these guys are now debating, disagreeing,
and so on.
And then you take the Supreme Court.
Supreme Court are the one-is the one which
has helped blacks, through the rulings of
the Court, to create the harmony.
So you shouldn't play down your role.
We are also copying from what you have achieved.
And also, what I have learned here is that
an open admission, open discussion-a problem
we have in Namibia and South Africa is there
are some white people who don't want to think
of the past.
They think Namibia started to be a country
from 21st of March, 1990.
So if you talk about the past, they think
we are going back to the past, the ugly history.
But here, what makes (the movement ?) is everything
is discussed.
It looks ugly, maybe; people look as they
are fighting.
But you solve it that way.
So I cannot teach you anything in this country.
You taught us.
But you also moved farther.
(You jumped the ?)-(inaudible)-by having a
black president.
I mean, that is-you might play it down, but
as Africa got independence in 1957, Kwame
Nkrumah became the first president-black president,
so to say.
And black Americans were encouraged, looking
up to Africa, that Pan-Africanism started-d'Ivoire,
went to Ghana, and so on, started from there.
Now, President Obama being the president of
the most powerful country also help many Africans
that us do proud.
If you go to Asia-some of you know Asia-sometimes
they'll be more racial, in a very unique way.
But when you walk around as a black man and
the American president is also black, it also
brings something.
So there's not much I can teach you about
that.
I think you are doing very well.
I worked here.
I-not work, I started here.
It was during that time more difficult.
But tolerance, things are happening.
But, you see, it's not overlooked.
NACCP-I forgot-
GAVIN: NAACP, mmm hmm.
GEINGOB: -was helped by white people.
Lawyers were-white people were-during the
march in the South, white were killed-three
whites were killed.
That's how the whole thing started.
So keep it up.
Just discuss.
You are a great country.
I cannot teach you anything about that because
you are doing well.
Leaning from you.
But, of course, Namibia also had colonial
period.
South Africa learned from there, too.
In the house I'm talking about, where there
is a slogan: no one must feel left out.
Not no one must be left out; no one must feel
left out, how that person feels.
So don't give the idea of feeling that they
are left out.
But only if the president was black, how can
anybody say blacks are left out?
So keep it up.
As for Namibia and United States, very good
relations, definitely.
Starting also from mandate system is Woodrow
Wilson, who said there should be no spoils
of war.
That's how the mandate system was established.
And when we were at the International Court
of Justice, the United States was there with
us.
We only parted ways when-(inaudible)-how to
go about after the Court failed to deliver.
Now the U.N. was terminating the mandate of
South Africa.
That's where we disagreed, on the modalities
how to go about.
So, as I said, Maurice (sp) and them, they
have been with us.
We go a long way.
We have many friends, American friends that
we have here.
So when we're in trouble, we'll call on you.
Don't worry.
We are together.
GAVIN: This is advice and a pep talk.
(Laughter.)
A: Thank you, President.
GAVIN: Want you here every week.
Thank you so much.
You have been very specific about the importance
of keeping time, and they are sticklers for
this at the Council as well.
So we're supposed to wrap up at seven, so
I'm going to ask Tammy (sp), please, to give
us the last question, and we'll all be very
concise.
Q: Thank you.
Mr. President, in your State of the Nation
address on Harambee, you explained to the
country the pillars that Mr. Alweendo-Minister
Alweendo discussed, and talked about sub-pillars,
and much of the speech was the overview.
But you also gave some examples that brought
the plan alive in terms of its effects on
ordinary Namibians, such as the recruitment
and training of unemployed youth to administer
food banks in urban areas, and in rural areas
to build toilets and to provide sanitation,
bringing together-simultaneously addressing
the youth unemployment and some of the issues
of hunger and need for sanitation and toilets.
Could you give just a few more examples of
how the Harambee plan in all its overviews
can come down to the local level and address
the problems of people?
GEINGOB: Tammy (sp) and Reid (sp) are old
friends-again, people who have-whom I work
with.
And they were in Namibia just recently.
So, yes, Harambee plan is really a detailed
plan.
The youth-there is a specific thing in engaging
the youth: vocational training; plus, also,
when it comes to-the food bank idea came-I
was in a church, and I pick up one lady who
is a daughter of one of the icons of the struggle,
and I was driving.
As we were driving to an outside location-really
where blacks are leaving, sorry to say-but
there were kids who were sitting, young boys,
angry, as we were driving.
And I saw them angry, and then I dropped her.
She took me around to the houses, looked super
angry.
(Inaudible)-when they're angry, (woman ?) said,
yes.
Then the idea of the food bank came from there,
that I said, look, we can use-(inaudible)-principle
of having stage committees.
Get those boys who are angry and give them
responsibility.
When they are working to clean up, first,
that street, to maintain security there-because
people are-women have been killed and so on,
so-by those people-maintain that security
there, then distribute food, and so on.
From the food-we're just kind of elaborating,
not just put in terms-it will be-we cited
from other examples.
So idea is to engage them.
(Inaudible)-but is to really engage them because
they are a majority.
And if they are unemployed, we are creating
future revolutionaries.
GAVIN: That's a very powerful message about
the importance of inclusion.
And I hope everyone will join me in thanking
President Geingob.
It's an incredible opportunity to get to hear
from you in such a conversational setting,
and I suspect that there are-there's more
than one person around the table mentally
making plans to visit Namibia and learn more,
or return to Namibia and be delighted once
again.
So thank you so very much.
We wish you all the best into the future.
(Applause.)
GEINGOB: Thank you very much.
Thank you.
(Applause.)
(END)
This is an uncorrected transcript.